ha 47 anni e rose l'apice della mia
carriera aveva appena venduto l'azienda
che ha uno cofondato
dove abbiamo lavorato come direttore
generale
mi sono contro la vita ho preso lezioni
di ballo
lotito tutto quello che anziani non
potevo fare come potete immaginare dopo
un po di tempo ho iniziato a dire adesso
farò da grande
io
avevo la volontà mi sentivo il bisogno
profondo di capire ma generalmente mi
ami per ceto susa veramente miope quanti
stato alla mia vita in quel momento
e mi ci è voluto un anno mezzo per
riflettere per capire in che direzione
andare ho dovuto avere la disciplina di
ignorare le fissazioni che alcune
offerte di lavoro
però ne è valsa la pena per j
in quello spazio
mi sono ri collegata con salsa con le
cose che amavo
ma oggi viviamo in un mondo della
comunicazione è ridotto a 280 caratteri
spazi inclusi
parliamo in poi a un bite indigno di
tito 15 secondi
un'email di più
più di impararlo con fischia di avere un
poco come a un successo di anonimo
centro lettere a oggi fonti di cli oggi
ha stoffa lumino l'ho letto
abbiamo tempi di qualificazione e
attenzioni ridotti
perché oggi viviamo in un mondo così
genetica
e non so stato mentale fisico in ultimo
è parlato quindi andiamo su una
scorciatoia
scendiamo e viviamo il mondo in modo
automatico il es
ma il pilot fantomatica va penzale
aeroplani
noi romani
sole abbiamo bisogno di tutto charlene
di usare auto pulp ilota i nomi tsi
turbo lezza io ma la clc mille
dobbiamo guardare no a noi capire
o i poveri
mi devo crescere in maniera cosciente
citeremo star punch e mi vecchi
non vivono più non sono più validi
smartphone si aggiornano quante volte
all'anno
e non
perché il mondo non si ferma per noi
continua diventare senza
multiculturale
multigenerazionale spinto a quanto pare
e noi cosa facciamo per essere al
corrente
se aveva di capire veramente
ascoltare identificare incaprettare
un'enorme fonte di informazione sono le
diverse è diventato uno delle capacità
più importante dei leader nel mondo di
oggi c'è nessuna sola persona può
bastare affrontare problemi di domani
da soli
nessun lega a o esperta in
fattori e rapida dimissione
all'incertezza politica o di mortacci
come e dove lavoriamo ci è stato
inviando
le aspirazione delle nuove generazioni
lottando e chandler nel mondo di mercato
e l'innovazione teologico che abbiamo
visto oggi
seriani hanno iniziato a lavorare
nessuna per mai detto
che raggiunge la posizione del video
show di successo ci si sono poi
concentrati
sui storia piuttosto che
tecnici o funzionale ma vedo adesso
warner vice
setti l'igiene e
il mondo un modello di linz
giusto a
comandare ego isolare a facci un
illusione coinvolgente con futura è in
grado di coinvolgere mobil mobilitare
piace a lavorare sodo
per far sì che questa visione avviene
sì lido ci andiamo li ha voluti
sannino
operano nel mondo di oggi
la cura e competenza ma neanche la
posizione gerarchica
processi più evoluti di controllo non
sono più dubbi la collezione
l'attenzione portano molto più lontano
grazie ci vedo non solo ci sono
veramente tra viadana tar e
affascinare la gente alle una cosa in
comune
lavorano
consistenza e profondamente su se stessa
sono vivamente coltivano un equilibrio
interno
la capacità che li lascia ad agire con
il mondo e rapida evoluzione quindi
possiamo fare da parte lega per superare
il nostro per i concetti da centimetri
ma di creare una nostra
ma valenza
lo vedo cioè alia 1
la storia ci spinge a pensare a
spingere in avere del nostro crew
milanese
approccio ormai non sono i dati ea
costruire la nostra società
maschili è venuti chi dice di uscire dal
cibo vino bene al corpo zone ma riandare
nuove idee e incarichi nostra crescita
così larga nel nostro gesù ci fidiamo
riusciamo a incassare
vedere cosa ci non avremmo mai voluti
non voluto da temi non avrebbe mai visto
in italiano
una lezione
parliamo di vista fino la risposta
succede qualcuno ripeto corriamo subito
agiamo in modo automatico e lines valuti
ci dicono di separare fino lohan ha
risposto la 20 ma viaggia palomba le
avete visto la cioè la frase mais
di una vertenza vota passeggeri uffici
una tensione
allo spazio fa il cielo e la panchina
della sanzione
lo spaccio
può essere per il caso diventa multi
facile percorrere quando noi ci siamo
analizziamo colpevole
quindi cosa vivono e pall una pausa
dalle funzioni tanto il
coach e dice ma stimo mai risposto c'e
uno spazio e spazio e non stere per
prendere una decisione
per fare una scelta la scelta ti lascia
a fregare il tuo comportamento
i tuoi obiettivi
e ne abbiamo già sentito parlare
in giro e servono tutti ci dicono che
non si batta per
previdenza del più forte ma
sopravvivenza
a più
intelligenza emotiva più padronanza
della propria emozione quindi la
capacità di
veramente capire e riconoscere proprio
pregiudizi infusi mozione guidano le
nostre decisioni
e che anche la capacità di dire le
emozioni motivazione degli altri ci dà
la possibilità di incappare le persone e
gli ambienti in cui lavoriamo
ma non è facile
non è facile
sempre a piegarci all'idea c'è tanto
stata da fare tutto quello che abbiamo
ottenuto tutto che abbiamo realizzato o
non essere valido non è facile metterci
in doc insomma ci vuole il coraggio e la
strada è sempre in salita
non è facile ahimé di capire che non c'è
stefano natile stessa energia e la
stessa velocità di imparare quindi
ingenti league
ti facciano un po
però
il fattore determinante per chi vuole
guidare il mondo di oggi
se uno vorrebbe trasformare il mondo def
iniziare prima
informare successo
il cambiamento che ci chiede il nostro
mondo e profondo
personale deve essere sostenibile
il poeta e filosofo a fiano rumi ha
detto ieri ero intelligente e volevo
cambiare il mondo
oggi sono saggio sto cambiando mezzo
nostro mondo oggi ho bisogno non solo di
intelligenza
ma anche di saggezza